what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
another episode of pearl daily where I
cover this week's treachery debauchery
and craziness today I have a special
guest on the show um you were actually
on one of our craziest episodes where I
think half the panel walked off right
yeah welcome to the show Nemo why don't
you introduce yourself to the people uh
thank you so much Pearl it's great to be
here I feel like I'm coming back home
you know yeah you know that was a crazy
night U my name is Nima y I'm the author
of a new book uh called how to not be a
[__] uh published by dng um and yeah
just just thrilled to be here uh again
thank you for having me yeah thank you
for coming um now you know I I have a I
have to this is my this is going to be
my standard question to the men that
come on the show women you know um I
have a women should have vote t-shirt
yeah would you wear a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt in
public yeah that's the right answer
honestly yeah that women shouldn't
[Laughter]
vote answer honestly be honest all right
if it's a no I mean If I Was A Bachelor
I it would be hard for me because you
know all the women were you know not
voting they'd be angrier and it' be much
harder to get a
[__] well guys if you want to wear
the women should have vot t-shirt you
know get yourself a women should of vote
t-shirt really I can't think of a could
you think of a faster way for women to
come up to you
no get yourself a women shot t-shirt the
link is in the description so all right
guys last night um I went on another
episode of Pierce Morgan now a lot of
you thought a lot of I saw your comments
Pearl will never get invited back Pearl
is never going to go back on Pierce
Morgan after they ambushed
me but I'm back and I'm better baby so I
went on Pierce Morgan last night and um
they had me on with a traditional
housewife and a feminist no can you can
you imagine how that went yeah yeah I
can already tell how that that's going
you know so what do you do you think
that traditional Housewives Are praised
by feminists
typically you know I think I think that
there's this like backwardness uh where
like my wife example is is actually a
liberal she's college graduate we live
in Germany and she likes being a
housewife she takes pride in it I think
I think it's empowering for a woman to
be at home and many women are happy
being at home doesn't mean she's not a
feminist I think you're a great example
of a feminist oh yeah of a real feminist
you know what I mean like a real
feminist not a toxic feminist yeah you
know what I mean like like a real like a
strong woman a good woman but I think a
lot of these women they're out of their
mind do you think I I find though that t
typical like the liberal chicks um I
don't think they really celebrate women
that stay home with the
kids yeah I mean it's it's a disorder
man like I I don't know like who would
they want raising their kids the
government the schools like I mean
that's what they're doing now you know
but you do see an uptick in um people
that are homeschooling their kids which
I do think is encouraging yeah but um so
let's let's go to Pierce Morgan and see
what they said how I don't know how is
the feminist movement of the last few
decades how has it gone for you and when
you look at it and see how women have
progressed do you think it's been
largely a Force for good or do you think
as the Trad wise do that perhaps we've
lost that sense of gender rules from one
of a better phrase which actually work
very well for mean I mean we've seen
families disappear you know um I saw a
study the other day that said only 25%
of I mean this is an American sta
American household to a family so um I
guess there's positives and there's
negatives but it's like at what cost you
know well 80 like 85 um 150 years ago
the average woman had seven kids 85% of
people were married I mean know that
also much High mortality women die very
young and you know I mean women were're
more depressed than ever before we're on
anti-depressants um women women over the
age of 45 are the least happy
demographic there are a lot of very
issue complex reasons for that I think
the issue you have is women like Emily
Rakowski you know marriage again I've
said this before marriage isn't marriage
anymore the average marriage is seven
years we have things like no fault
divorce leave if you're unhappy so what
does that mean marriage isn't marriage
anymore because there have been so many
marriages over the course of history
where people have been very unhappy
either the man or the woman has been
very unhappy and they've been forced
basically to stay in a marriage it could
have been an abusive marriage abusive
marriage and we have one life why would
you spend it with someone marriage was
about Duty and that this is the problem
we have with women like women men tend
to be better people than us yeah they
really do they tend no they they tend to
do the right things
theyes I AG I mean there's a reason we
have phrases like a man of his word
right not a woman of her word because
men men will actually stick things out
women when stick gets hard we just leave
and you're proving you're proving my
point what was what was your what was
your first answer my happiness right of
course everyone deserves to be happy
every the family doesn't work when it's
about you supposed to be about your kids
and that's the pro that's the
problem there's a balance and a
compromise in relationship am I allow to
talk now
or look I think relationships are about
balance they're about compromise they're
about knowing understanding yourself
learning to you know no understand
another person eventually potentially if
you want to Bringing children into the
world and teaching them how to do that
as well teaching them to balance a sense
of their own identity with the love that
they have for for another person and you
know for example I know um an older
woman actually his friend of our family
who um got divorced at about 60 she had
you know this lovely family they were
together since they were 18 and she said
I got to a point after I'd stopped being
a mother and you know I was just kind of
getting on I realized I'd lost my sense
of who I was and I didn't really feel
like I knew who I was anymore because
I'd always just been a wife and a mother
and I wanted to go out and explore that
and I think that's fantastic what TR
what is
traditionalism um I don't know what you
think I would say I would say a modern
mentality is me before the family I
would say traditional tradition ism is
the family before me especially in women
so and so and so what I actually it's
interesting you said 60-year-olds cuz
you know I've interviewed 600 700 people
roughly in the past year and a half I've
done hundreds of shows interviewing
people about relationships and what I
find is the 60-year-olds tend to a lot
of those women LED their daughters
astray you know there there's a reason
we're in this mess right a lot of those
women had the wrong mentality when it
came to marriage and had exactly the
mentality that you're talking about
where
prioritize balancing one's own sense of
identity with compromise relationship
myself before the marriage but that's
again and it's really unfortunate I
would say the women of Our Generation
really are are suffering because of the
advice of the women of the past there's
an interesting point here right which is
that we do live in a very
individualistic society and we're all
told actually I think a lot of the time
in our relationships as well you have to
be a certain way if you want to receive
love you have to abide by these these
Norms you have to be a certain level of
attractiveness you have to earn a
certain amount of money it's all about
you that's the what love it so what what
did you think of the clip I think you
made some good points yeah I think you
made some good points what did you what
what what happened after that like what
obviously you two aren't having a aren't
best friends right well I mean everyone
argues and just goes
home especially when you like do this a
lot like you just kind of you know yeah
even even the first girl I went on with
Pierce Morgan like I say hi to her every
time I see her you know um but you know
it's interesting because I I listen
carefully to like the words that they
say yeah and how she was saying
love um I I needed to know who I was and
like she was talking about the
60-year-old woman who divorced her
husband because she felt like her she
lost her sense of self yeah and I just
thought to myself you know aren't you
isn't your identity supposed to be in
your family yeah and I I don't know what
what I find is those women um just kind
of listen to feminists for too long and
these like this m me me culture and so
you know they hit 60 and they think the
grass is greener on the other side I
don't know what the hell you think is on
the other side of a divorce that's 60
yeah yeah pretty lonely man getting old
and lonely is scary yeah and then she
she talked about um receiving love and
she's said you shouldn't have to be a
certain way to receive love and I
thought this was interesting because men
know that they have to be somebody in
order to get into a relationship right
you can't you can't just be a loser and
receive love like I in my opinion the
only people that deserve love are
children and then after that it's really
the type of person you are and the
character you have yeah yeah I think I
think you nailed it yeah what what do
you what do you think about a woman
getting divorced at 60 because she needs
to figure out who she is did they have
do she still have kids at home no I
think they're
gone it's sad because you know being
alone when you get old if you get sick
and no one's there that's [__] it's
horrifying to get sick alone already
yeah but imagine being sick and not
having someone there with you at the
hospital and then coming home
empty that's really scary man yeah yeah
I I I I I don't think that's that's hard
yeah yeah that's what and that's what
aging aging ain't for the weak-hearted
man agent aging is undefeated you know
as you get older and older and and uh
you see other friends that are in their
60s and they have kids grandkids kids
that love them you know you can go out
do Instagram pictures all day you want
right but at when you come home you know
if if you're alone that's that's really
horrifying well and the average person
lives to be I think 77 um but you could
live to be 90 you know so what does a
woman's life look like cuz women tend to
live longer than men so what does a
woman's life look like she gets divorced
at 60 let what if she lives to be 90 40
years in your elderly years as a chick
yeah good God what do you think's on the
other side of that and it's funny um I
have an aunt that got married pretty
like later in life um and I'm I'm
talking like I think she was in her 60s
and she married a guy that was like 10
years older than her this is an
exception it's not the rule but even he
was talking about how at like the
nursing homes or whatever that he had
like four women did she pick from and he
picked
oh man you I mean so these women cuz a
lot of them it was funny my um my my
grandma they she passed away but before
she died my Grandpa died like 15 years
before her and when I was in high school
I went to she took me to something with
all her like friends right and it was so
funny because listening to them talking
about dating it it sounded like
teenagers you know what I mean where I
was like why are the like I'm like but
it was kind of the same stuff where it's
like there's only a couple guys that go
around they date a guy for like one of
them was talking about a guy she was
dating and she's like yeah he died yeah
so it's like what what do you think's on
the other side of this yeah it's a good
point yeah you know you know when you're
in your 20s and 30s it's like every year
Invincible you think it's like life goes
on forever but in reality you know you
do get older yeah like age is undefeated
it's really um interesting I like to
look at like case studies of people like
that were kind of in the spotlight and
the media and it's interesting to see
like some of the younger celebrity women
kind of age out like Madonna yeah
Britney Spears well when you see like
the level of attention they got and they
kind of went crazy when they went older
it's like the women of my generation oh
my like with
Instagram it's going to be interesting
to see like where we are in 20 years
yeah speaking of Aging right yeah yeah
yeah all right so this was my tweet no
35-year-old and I want to explain it to
you before cuz people people tend to get
triggered before they they kind of see
my mindset so I had a tweet I said no
35-year-old women aren't that hot none
will compete with the average in shape
21-year old don't shoot the messenger
now the reason I had this thought was
because I would see top 35-year-old
women that were just really really
attractive right the models the whatever
and I would think to myself on an
average college campus you could
probably find like 10 chicks that are
equally as good-looking as them if not
more now it's not to say that there's no
women that are attractive at 35 or
pretty but we live in this delusion
where we tell women they're going to be
hot forever and at 35 most women would
aim to have a family and kids and really
have more of an identity in their
character over their looks yeah but
every time I I make a broad generalized
statement where I know there's
exceptions but we're talking about the
rule right yeah everyone gets mad and
the wives just start arguing with me
about their hotness yeah yeah and so
Ashley Sinclair um says Pearl has
started adding the qualifier in shape
now because it's not that 22y old is
hotter than 32 it's just by 33 many
women get fat and let themselves go at
22 it's less likely that was my argument
months ago seems I convinced her now I'd
like to say to this Ashley chick no you
did not convince me I would say that if
you have a 22-year-old chick that is not
fat in general they're hotter than a 32y
old chick and that same chick is in
general going to be hotter at 22 than 32
and I think you see this in the modeling
industry where women age out pretty
quickly you you said you worked with
models in New York yeah I I worked with
fashion models in New York City for
about 10 years okay and I would bring
them out to the nightclub and I would
charge a fee and I remember that a lot
of the models they come in at 17 18 Full
of Life full of energy full
optimism um then maybe about 3 four
years later if they're still even in New
York they're beaten down they're
destroyed you know um age is undefeated
again and you're constantly competing
with women that are 17 18
19 um and back then you know fashion
models was much more prestigious than
you know the weird stuff you see in
2020 models yeah yeah like the New York
Fashion Week Paris Fashion Week it
wasn't that it was even back then it was
sort of like odd but now it's just
become next next tier of odd yeah back
then it was actually prestigious to work
with fashion models yeah um but the idea
that women you they fall off because
you're constantly competing with you
know young women and my thought is when
I said that hot that to me when you say
you're that hot by 35 you should be
beautiful because your character in my
opinion your character should be
developed to the point where you're
beautiful you're not hot anymore you're
a wife you're a mother yeah but it's
like how hot do you want to be as a mom
don't you want to be beautiful you
know and so when I said that hot I'm
like isn't that like top 10% of beauty
and look at Margot Robbie right she was
a smoke show God in Wolf of Wall Street
all the men loved her now you know and
it's interesting you see this happen to
the women when they're younger they're
in the they're in the movies that Mark
it to men so Wolf of Wall Street Megan
Fox Transformers they get old they start
being cast in in movies that are for
women wow you notice that so like Margo
Robbie Barbie that's like women watch
that wow and I think it's cuz women
don't like to see women that hot on TV
wow but men do so like in the Man movies
you'll see like the hottest CH I mean
all the hottest chicks are in the in the
Man movies you know yeah yeah yeah okay
so I responded to this chick because I
said no by 33 you're less hot than 23
The Only Exception is if you were obese
you know I was like all right if the
23-year-old was fat that's not really
the same territory but you get less hot
as you get older by 35 most chicks Have
Wrinkles sag a bit and have under other
indicators of Aging do not shoot the
messenger is this
untrue I think you nailed it I think she
hates you because you nailed
it it's like it's okay it's I didn't say
you're a bad person so I I have this um
thing where I talk about sing yeah and I
I think that simps are equally as as bad
as the modern women yeah because they
allow us to live in delusion and a lot
of times what I what I Noti is when men
process information their first reaction
in general is if it's true yeah unless
they're simping yeah then because women
process information like individually so
they'll say like how does this apply to
me like if I say nope a 22-year-old is
hotter than a 32y old you know they'll
say well but I they're like their
reaction is well but I was but I'm
hotter now than I was at 20 you know
which it's usually cat but you know what
I'm saying yeah so where men will will
think more in general yeah except for
the simps so now Dr interracial says my
wife is 63 and hotter than
Pearl and it's funny because I was never
talking about his wife I was never
talking about my looks yet they feel the
need to insult me or you know by
tweeting me pictures of his wife like
this is weird this is weird Behavior
yeah the I idea that you're going to use
your wife an image of your wife and then
attack someone's daughter that's just a
poor way poor taste of showing his point
like I understand he's sing for his wife
but he's
also degrading another man's daughter so
I don't really look at him as a guy of
high moral Authority like he could have
proved his point without because at the
end of the day you're actually another
man's daughter I have a daughter as a
man you'll never know what that feels
like bro you know what I mean yeah so
the fact that he degraded you to make an
example is disgusting who does he think
he is I mean he's not he's no moral
Authority this is he probably votes for
Kamala you know what I'm saying right
actually I think he's a conservative but
yeah I don't understand probably a
closet liberal I don't know but that's
the thing it's like you know I it's like
the guys like this that cosign us and
make us think we're like hot for a
lifetime and it's just not true again
when you get older you should you should
be beautiful you your goal shouldn't be
to be like a sex object it should be to
be beautiful for your family and your
husband you know because there's
something about like even if it's like
an older woman that is just like really
happy with her family and her children
and you you know you know what I mean
where like I I don't know who comes to
your head but there's like a couple
women that come to mind where okay
they're a bit older but it's like seeing
them interact with their husband and
their family they're just beautiful
they're not sexy they're not hot they're
they're Grandma they're mom but they're
it's beautiful because they're not
trying to be a sex object anymore yeah
yeah and like and hot to me when you say
hot that that implies more of like a sex
object beautiful is like something
that's more intangible you know yeah now
facts simply aren't facts PE so again
these women they start tweeting at me
they're
selfies I think I think I think it's
just looking at the Tweet is crazy I
mean it's it's
yeah so that was her I guess younger on
the left and then on the right and so I
just you know there there's her she
looks like a nice girl yeah that's her
daughter no I mean that's like that's
her at 32 I guess and that was her at 22
so 22 and then 10 years later so and
then but like what's the point of like
doing this body
comparison like does that take away from
your main point that you made like you
still made a good valid point like what
what do this become like a competition
of focusing on each other looks it's
distracting from the main topic well so
yeah and I responded and I'm like all
you did was get more
[Laughter]
naked I'm like you just like took off
your clothes yeah yeah but I've just
noticed whenever I tweet anything about
younger being hotter it's like women
were so used to be like think look at
marketing like you just notice all the
movies are casting older women all the
model are getting older it's just like
paning yeah it is that's not what men
any if you want to look at like what men
like look at the male movies and look at
whose cast like wasn't Avengers it was
Scarlett Johansson yeah yeah I mean I've
I've seen I've seen I've been you know
I've been like right with Scarlett
Johansson in a New York City Deli in in
trca we live in the same neighborhood
and she's actually like a very petite
small girl yeah and like very small
petite and very quiet so when I see her
in the superhero movies I'm I'm sort of
like it's so far from what reality
actually like yeah it's beyond beyond
far from what reality is like um so I
want to give you like my take on
marriage in 2023 I want to give you my
take so and you give me your take too
yeah I think marriage traditional
marriage is beautiful I love seeing
couples that like make that work I think
it is amazing um but what I what I don't
want is men not making an informed
decision so I think that men should be
aware of the risks that come with it so
that that's kind of my opinion and I I
think that some men and this is
regardless of what I say or I don't say
you're with the laws being how they are
you're going to keep seeing men walk
away from Marriage until the laws change
it's going to be a bigger and bigger
number every year regardless of what
Pearl says because again men are kind of
logical right so they kind of weigh the
risks of marriage and the rewards and
you know sometimes they'll meet a girl
where the reward is worth it
right and they'll say you know what I
know this system's against me some guys
go to different countries to figure this
out like it just depends on the guy yeah
um but until we start lowering the risks
the women of 2023 are definitely worse
than the women 20 years ago those women
are worse than the we we're just seeing
a trend across the board I don't say
this in a happy way I'm not happy about
it but it's becoming more and more
difficult for men to be traditional
because many men are punished for being
traditional yeah and um what I see a lot
of times it's the men that say you know
what this is too much I don't want to do
it they're shamed by the traditional
conservatives for making that choice and
I think for
men sometimes and and I think it depends
on the guy right so you know I think a
YouTuber is going to have a very
different experience than say a factory
worker yeah and you know we need Factory
workers for this country to run we need
truckers we need plumbers and I think
they just sometimes have a hard time and
a lot of times those are the guys we see
like walk away does that make sense yeah
because you know again with the
Instagram economy it's really hard to
have the average woman stay unless
you're exceptional as a man yeah
unfortunately I don't say this in like a
happy way so cernovich says 90% of men
speaking out against marriage aren't
sought after the truth is that a desired
man who isn't a sociopath will date
widely enough until he meets someone who
has his number and that's it the Playboy
or whatever is a goober myth from a beer
commercial so um I wanted to talk about
the first part in my experience and this
is just from like interviewing guys
getting screwed in divorce I I think a
lot of the guys that speak out against
marriage actually had success in dating
and got married and then just got
screwed over yeah yeah I I think I I'm a
big fan of Mike I think he's a great guy
he's a great family guy I I agree with
him in regards to 90% of men who speak
out again 90% of men speaking out
against marriage aren't sought after
okay I mean if I couldn't get any
[__] and I had six inches taken off
my
dick I would probably have the same
Theory yeah see I disagree I disagree
and no no no that that's it it's just
it's just I think that I think that
there are a lot of attractive men yeah
that are actually able I don't want to
use the word dominate to disrespect all
the the the loving and respectful wives
out there but they are the dominant
force in the family as the clear
Undisputed leader like to the point
where you can have a woman say yeah you
are the man and you are the leader now
that doesn't mean she's the donkey or
the cow in the relationship you still
love your wife you treat her good but I
do think that there are a group of men
who are good ladies men yeah these are
the sort of men that are ladies men
these are the sort of men that are good
with women and they get a wife that is
actually and I don't want to use the
word subservient but they are very
respectful and they admire their
husband are there a lot of guys that are
simps and get walked over we both know
the answer to that well I think I think
you're just if the answer is these men
are that are complaining are are they're
just subservient men like do you think
60% of men aren't good enough for
marriage cuz 60% of men aren't looking
for marriage in relationships put it
like this bro so so like in my head it's
like the average man used to be able to
get an average woman you know he didn't
have to be this like six foot tall he
didn't have to be have this amazing job
in order to attract a woman it was like
an average guy could get a 120 pound
virgin and my and Mike in Mike's defense
yeah let's just say for example Mike
here Mike is like 6'4 at build
successful highly intelligent his wife I
can I've never met his wife but I from
what I see his wife respects him so he
might have not the same but that doesn't
mean every guy can do what he did well
that's that's my point is a lot of times
the guys that come at this are kind of
like you know rich men tend to stay
married longer right they they tend to
their the divorce rate is like 25% among
like rich men I don't know that yeah so
I think they live in a different reality
than the average men in this country so
I I'll give you an example one of the
top um in America anyway one of the top
places people are employed is
truckers okay yeah so and the average
man makes $45,000 a year I don't think
those men are losers I think I think a
lot of times they speak down on the men
that allow us to do what we do right
like doing this someone in a factory had
to make this microphone you know what I
mean like we need Factory workers we
need truckers we need plumbers and I I
think that average women don't respect
average men anymore and I think it is
very risky because what I've seen like
just doing the divorce documentary is
the men that get screwed over the most
aren't the rich men the rich men might
pay the most but they can kind of
recover and make make their money back
later do you know what I mean yeah it's
the average men are the ones like that
I've seen like commit suicide in divorce
or um like I would say on the brink of
suicide are ones that get false
accusations or um worked the same job
for 20 years and then their wife took
half like imagine like the average
average divorce is 46 years old so again
like my my um my one point is that a lot
of the men that talk about this they're
not over the average age of first
divorce and a third of them will uh half
of them will divorce if they're
Christian it's like a quarter right and
a lot of the men that commit suicide in
this country over this stuff are the men
that works 20 years then their wife
takes half their [__] alienates them
from their children and they they
haven't seen them in many many like
sometimes it's like 2 3 years and these
are the Uber drivers the truck drivers
the plumbers the factory like these are
average men um and so I think a lot of
times like the tall good-look successful
men will kind of [__] on them but most
of them can't do what they do without
them yeah I mean speak to your point
about plumbers in particular plumbers
some construction workers if you think
about firefighters yeah these are
occupations also because of their
exposure to that environment they may be
getting cancer at a higher rate than a
general population wow I didn't even
think about that yeah so not only is
that plumber maybe more exposed to an
environment and toxins that give them a
higher rate of probability of getting
cancer same with the firefighter you
should see how many of them get cancer
or or or or or or some of our veterans
right right so so not only are they not
making a high income they're more
exposed to these chronic
conditions I think they for sure deserve
much more respect at the very least Top
Class Healthcare but that's that's my
point is I just think like a lot of
times they'll they'll kind of say that
they're crybabies or whatever but it's
like no I I don't I don't think it's
these men that can't get wom this is
just my experience maybe you think
differently but I don't see them as
these men that can't get women I see
them as average men who thought they
signed up for the wife and kids and were
absolutely devastated when they had no
idea what family court is like yeah and
and I think until you've really spent
like a week in Family Court to see no
these were not loser men these were not
men that couldn't get it's just it's the
average men that built this country that
are getting absolutely destroyed by
these women and it's not a fringe cases
it's not exceptions like this is common
and I do this sun shows all the time
I'll say do you know a guy that's been
falsely accused raise your hand the
whole room raises their hand you know
like like this is a huge risk for men
and I I don't say don't do it I think
you know sometimes you find a woman that
you think is worth the risk and I think
that's beautiful but what I don't think
is good is to encourage young men to be
naive yeah well well to Mike's credit he
did say
90% I don't even think it's that high
what do you think I mean okay do you
think 60% of men are losers 45% of men
are 45% of men run the infrastructure of
this country so that means one out of
every two men does a job that helps you
live the way you live so they do the
factory workers they're they're plumbers
they're truckers they build the
buildings Drive the roads and I think
it's like I I I don't really like
influencers [__] on the average men
that allow us to do what they do are
they just losers half of the men that
run this country are just whining that
they can't get women you know th those
men used to get a wife and a kids that
used to be the standard and like uh
what's changed I don't think they're
losers you know yeah it's it's like the
cringe of uh you know what's changed is
look at the media look at the movies
like I saw Jennifer Lawrence poster
right here in London yeah right when I
get here I see a Jennifer Lawrence
poster and I like it's like the cringe
inside of me was so intense there's a
Jennifer a Jennifer Lawrence poster and
she's this strong dominant intelligent
woman oh yeah and then she's next to a
this weak no you know
docile idiotic awkward young man yeah
and I'm just there thinking why are we
continuously making these men we're
shaming these men into Oblivion correct
then other women watch it and think this
is this is it like the man's supposed to
be subservient yeah meanwhile China's
raising strong men Russia's raising
strong men Iran is Raising strong men
we're going to get we're gonna we're
this is like the it's like Elon Musk
said like this feels like the Roman
Empire like we're falling apart our men
have become women bro yeah well the
women have become men too and but in but
they in reality when it's Chinese men
against American women we lose
correct there's a there's a point when
reality comes to
everyone's face yeah we can't hide from
reality forever but that's my point cuz
like if he's if he's saying that the the
men that are walking away
90% are just losers well then then
you're calling 63% of American men
losers really
63% are you so amazing like like it's
just I I just think that's a bit
conceited I think I think you kind of
have to hear where they're coming from
and I I don't I really I you know at
first like I kind of had similar
thoughts but then after interviewing
like man after man I I've interviewed
men that made six figures that this
happened to yeah I've interviewed men
that like I I I just interviewed a guy
who's a Bollywood actor so he was a he
he had a modeling contract he was an
actor same thing happened to him he was
just a loser really and now he hasn't
seen his kids in three years three like
imagine what that would do to you you
have a daughter how old is she one
imagine if you haven't seen her in 3
years because and I'm not I pray this
would never happen to you so don't take
this as like you know but like imagine
what that would do to you as a guy like
you haven't seen like the person you
love more than anyone in the world for
three years now his daughter or I think
actually it was a son refuses to say his
name because of all the trash the mom
has talked about him he had he had money
right and he was fighting in court and
he he can't see his kid so is is he just
a loser who's saying there's no and he
even said I wanted the fairy tale ending
I thought I found my happily ever after
he says this to me and this is a guy
that's tall rich goodlooking and he's
better off than I I would argue he has a
better shot at recovering than say a
factory worker which is one of the
number one like that's one of the number
one wapes people are employed in America
truckers Factory where Uber drivers are
getting pretty big you know so I mean I
mean to to your point look at what's
happening to Russell bran and uh correct
the innocent family men uh Tristan and
Andrew Tate I mean you basically have
women from years ago who can just
literally engage in what would normal
people would call slander and defamation
of character but now these have become
just regular things you can say to
destroy damage smear a man's entire
career and you have complete immunity
from prose ution you have complete
immunity in court you can just destroy
she can't those women could now just say
uh maybe it wasn't true they walk away
but they've already caused millions of
dollars of damage and my my whole point
is until you change some of these
systems it's it it's systematic well men
men just are going to keep walking
regardless of what because they always
say I'm leading I'm leading men into
destruction regardless of what I say
you're going to see the same thing the
irony that you would be leading I know I
know no I mean this is like in 1984 like
the idea that you would be doing that
when you're suggesting hey this justice
system this is systematic abuse of fair
Justice for men and not only that Pearl
we're literally encouraging
incentivizing and celebrating women to
engage in slander defamation of
character and to financially damage men
with no fin no legal repercussions we're
literally every woman every man like
Russell bran that goes down or an
innocent family man like Tristan Tate
and Andrew Tate when they see that
freedom is taken we are literally
rewarding and encouraging a million
other women to do the same to someone in
their local Town yeah yeah and that's
that's what's horrifying yeah and that's
that's why I don't really like when this
is why like and this is why I'm glad we
could have this conversation I empath
like I had nine siblings my parents are
still married like people think I have
this like evil I've seen my parents fil
to multi-million dollar business
together they had 10 kids like I hope my
daughter talks about me the way you talk
about it yeah yeah like exactly dad I
have I have seen the upside of marriage
and I never discount that it's there but
you
know what I would describe divorce as
for many men is death and this might
sound dramatic but I mean imagine not
seeing your daughter for years that's
death to imagine a lot of these men
their reality is that another man is
going to have more influence on their
child than them because 20% of divorces
they only see their daughter every other
weekend the other 20% it's like limited
so half of divorces the man has very
little to no contact with his child that
is he has no control over what men come
into like like that's death to a man and
that and I think that's even worse than
the financial stuff I think go so many
guys would give up all their money just
to see their kids and they and they I I
meet them and so to act like okay you
know a guy saying you know that's just
too much of a risk for me and walking
away as like a loser I just don't buy it
I think until you fix the system we're
never going to have progress well do you
think only fans should be legal in
America as a woman I I think I would ban
it if it was up to me I I think it
should be illegal because I just think
right now and I'm not saying like
obviously there's going to be women that
get away with it or whatever but I guess
you kind of have to ask your question in
a society should we ban things that are
immoral
and some people would say no people are
going to do it every anyway but I guess
what what formed my opinion was weed
okay now when I was in high school weed
was kind of
like it was like taboo a bit more like I
know like people smoked it whatever but
I just think like there's been a change
in society in America since you can like
go down the street and buy it where
obviously people were going to smoke it
anyway but I don't really like the idea
of there being a store front that anyone
can go and just buy the weed we all know
what's going to happen but at least when
they do it it's like how do I put it
it's more behind closed doors I'm not
even I don't even really care if they go
after them that much I just don't like
living in a world where like it's like
easy to get now weed is one thing but I
think of the idea of like
prostitution do I like the idea of it
being like Amsterdam where it's like
even though men do it anyway in America
right obviously like Vegas whatever I
don't really like the idea of raising my
kids in a world where prostitution is
just like normalized to be out in public
yeah and I would say the same thing with
only fans like obviously they're going
to figure out ways to do it but at least
like let's let's start Banning them like
so they can't publicly talk about it
anymore you know what I mean so they
can't publicly promote it if you figure
out a way to do it against the law fine
I don't care right I'm not saying we
should expend tons of police resources
going after them whatever but at least
guys like I just don't want to be in a
world like where it's so open uh
Playboys settle down once they find a
woman they think is worth settling down
for um okay I think there's two types I
think there's the type of Playboy that
will be single forever like I don't see
Drake ever getting married and now I
know I use Drake as an example I know
he's an exception but I think what you
see in celebrities you also see like the
micro versions of them in like the town
so like the Drake of is they're never
getting married you know I some I I
wonder if do you think Drake is actually
gay like he's just I think he's by I
think Yeah Yeah by I think he's probably
by yeah I think he's by or um I think a
lot of guys that go down the sexuality
route too hard end up like [__]
[__] and stuff yeah like that just I
don't know I just I I I feel like porn
kind of leads men that way and I the
same way I think extreme attention ruins
women I think extreme sex kind of ruins
men like when at a young age they get
access to like their wildest sexual
fantasies I think that kind of some of
them get kind of wacky and I think Drake
kind of kind of it looks like that with
the nail polish and [__] yeah it is
feminine for Drake to have like the nail
polish what's next he's going to wear a
wig like what's next is he going to wear
a skirt like you know where do we draw
it a la um and you know what's
interesting okay there's like a
different view on
bisexuality of the Next
Generation Um and I I had this I was on
a live once with um my sister this was
like a year and a half ago my sister was
in England and um they asked me if I
would ever date a guy that was by and I
said oh hell no like if if you kissed a
man once it's over with ew ew ew ew and
he's like I bet you your little sister
has a different view on it because she's
um my little sister's seven six six
seven years younger than me um and I go
up to her and I ask her and my next
little sister and they're like oh we
don't
care and it seems to be like a more
accepted thing now like the buy stuff
with guys I don't like it but yeah yeah
yeah it's almost like Drake's making it
popular bad money yeah yeah Vibe right
yeah they're pushing it um okay so um
what do you think about Playboys though
you think um what what percent of
playboys settle down I think a lot of
the Playboys that I know generally will
settle down in their late 30s early 40s
okay late 30s early and I think if they
don't meet if they don't catch that
train they may just be Playboys okay so
the last um the last topic
today and all right so Carrie Washington
reveals that she found out her dad
wasn't her biological father in her
Memoir Thicker Than Water Carrie
Washington unveils a life altering
Revelation her biological father is not
who she believed him to be this
disclosure came as she prepared to
participate in the PBS series Finding
Your Roots where celebrities traced
their ancestry through DNA testing her
parents who had concealed this Truth for
decades opted to share it privately
before the TV show their decision to
keep this information from her had a
profound impact on Washington who had
battled anxiety self-esteem issues and
an eating disorder for years possibly
due to subconsciously sensing the
undisclosed secret despite her parents
initial reluctance Washington penned the
Memoir to share her authentic story
thicker than water thicker than water
provides an intimate glimpse into her
life as an artist Advocate mother
daughter wife and black woman aiming to
offer readers insights into her
experiences and promote greater
self-compassion and empathy the
revelation also deepened her connection
with her parents fostering a stronger
sense of love compassion and
understanding I mean if there's any race
that can go 40 plus years without
admitting they adopted their
kid black people have it the
best no one's going to be asking uh why
they don't look like oh I
[Music]
see wow I can't believe they they waited
till their 40s isn't that crazy do you
think that's wrong for them to keep that
secret it's interesting I've been on
both ends of yeah these are such tough
questions you know what I'm saying like
these are like real hard
hard you know what's interesting so I um
I've been on both ends of adoption so my
parents adopted three kids and they also
gave up one so um my mom and dad same
parents but they got pregnant when my
mom was like I think 17 something like
that 18 um they ended up giving that kid
up and I didn't meet him till he was 30
and then on the other hand um and I
actually had no idea like I I you don't
even understand when they told us um we
like everyone didn't believe them like
they're like oh um we have a brother his
name is Greg we're like what kind of
name is Greg like whatever which is a
fine name we're just kidding but you
know um and then on the other hand we
adopted
teenagers and it's interesting what it
actually taught me was I used to always
think that environment was the most
important thing uh because of the single
mother home stat so I always thought it
was all about environment no bi biology
my brother Greg is actually so similar
to us and think about it 30 years never
met us since he was a baby and he He
Walks Like Us talks like us you know and
on the other hand um the three that we
adopted which we adopted them as
teenagers but you you
also you kind of see like I've noticed
that if you don't adopt a kid before
it's really hard to like um they're
pretty their brain's pretty much
developed so if they have habits or
something it's pretty tough to like kind
of change them to be honest or like if
there's ISS because I've I've seen um I
saw um a couple at my church a couple
years ago they adopted one um kid that
was one and a half and one that was like
four and the one that was four always
had issues the one that was one and a
half didn't and to me it kind of said
like if you don't get them I guess soon
enough it's tough to mold them but at
the the end of the day people have
biological predispositions regardless
and sometimes you can't override them
and so I would guess I don't know if she
had siblings or whatever but I would
guess that she probably felt like a
disconnect with her siblings because I
just think that there's something like
blood is thicker than water and there is
something about like you know being
someone's biological sibling and like a
level of like closeness I guess you
can't really replicate through adoption
I mean Carrie Washington's beautiful I
she's stunning yeah she's beautiful what
do you think about um men that find out
that their kid isn't theirs like a 33%
of people that get their DNA tested um
to see if it's um what's it called they
go to like you know test their DNA 33%
find out the kids's not theirs you know
what's crazy I told my wife in the very
beginning I'm like we're doing a DNA
test no matter what basically yeah but
my daughter has such a striking image to
me that it makes it pretty clear uh it's
my daughter but I would and I have I not
trust my wife she's a loyal wife but I'm
just so paranoid
um but if I were to find out that it's
not my daughter and she cheated on me
but you know as a as a married man i' I
mean I would be devastated man yeah I
would be devastated I think any guy
would be devastated I
mean should there be a law that
protects men from oh I think it should
be at Birth the mandatory DNA
testing do you think it should be a law
that a man who got a woman
pregnant um he has to be able to sign
off before a woman gets an
abortion oh that's a good question
because you because a woman I would I
would ban abortion in Pearl's world I
don't believe in it because I guess the
argument is is that a woman knows she's
the mother but she can't necessarily say
who's the
father I think that women that do that
should go to jail for
fraud so it CH like I I think if a guy
cons someone out of their
money he goes to jail why is why is it
that a woman that CS a man not only of
his money but his time and resources
doesn't go to jail for
fraud yeah I mean think about it like I
think about a man and a woman having sex
and and he says I'm about to come inside
of you and she says yeah I want you to
come inside of me then she gets pregnant
right and she gets pregnant and she says
I'm getting an abortion and the man says
don't get an abortion I have the
financial means I can take care of the
kid can't do anything yeah and I think
that I think that there's no justice for
men in that regard I've like have you
seen I've actually had that happen to me
no you had I was in high school I was 18
she you know and and you know both our
families could have afforded keeping the
kid and my ex-girlfriend at that time
went and got an abortion and I was
against it and I and I just kept
thinking like how is it possible that
you can get an abortion without my
consent and she could do it wow and she
did now I'm 43 yeah think about it 25
years later I'm still angry about it
that was your kid my kid would have been
24 right now
wow no and I think it's it's like the
other side that we don't really hear
about cuz people don't care about like
what the men think about it's her body
her choice I even told her like hey if
you don't want the child give her to me
give them to me I'll take care of it I
can take care of it yeah but I didn't
have any choice it's the lopsided of our
you know fake justice system well I
don't even so if it was up to me like I
wouldn't I I'm I just don't I'm pro-life
I don't believe abortion but but even so
I think that would be a compromise that
could make it more fair at Le at the
very very least right yeah because I
hear two arguments one is that the cat's
already out of the bag there's no going
back um you know when it comes to birth
control abortion all that stuff and the
other side is there like we should go
back to
traditionalism um from a policy
perspective so I you know I I could hear
both arguments but I at least think at
the very start we need to make it more
fair for men definitely so especially
when you know like there's clear
evidence that hey they were boyfriend
girlfriend they were together yeah I
mean I was specifically told for example
in my case that she wanted to have a
child and it wasn't until her father
pressured
her um that it worked out that she got
it oh her her dad told her to abort I
her oh
wow actually my high school I didn't get
along with her dad I didn't have a great
relationship with her dad um and uh
anyway so the point is is that I didn't
have a say in it and they basically
murdered my child and I got away they
got away with it
all right guys like the video on your
way out let's get this to 2,000 likes
because that is the most important
metric that YouTube uses also get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
today um all of these problems in
society really just started from women
voting all right get yourself a t-shirt
like the video and I'll talk to you next
time